there's a lot of butt problems I'm dr.
Terry Dubrow i'm dr. paul nassif or
we're here to answer your burning
questions about bashed how did you two
team up
that's a hue sir let me start I had sort
of a micropenis consult day in my office
and he no no he was my first appointment
he pulled it down and went I'm living
well over there and so I said yeah I
don't have that problem I'm good but I'm
not that good yet so come back when I've
got a solution to the mini micro penis
phenomenon and then maybe I can help you
I met him it's I get a call from my
sister like oh we met the funniest funny
start to Newport Beach and they
introduced me to dr. Terry Dubrow do you
think things like social media and
filters play a role in the tight working
out the surgeries you and I already know
that yeah I mean it's really changed
that we call it selfie dysmorphia where
patients are trying to look like an
idealized version of themselves not the
way they actually look they bring their
selfie photos in and they say I want to
look like this well that's a filter and
last time we checked scalpel is not a
filter so use the filter don't use the
scalpel what is the most common
procedure women ask for at your office
what's the most common procedure men ask
for so women
Botox for me breast revision surgery men
I would say Botox yes why despite after
five seasons of botched haven't you been
able to reduce your body fat dr. Nassif
go know it seems like Brazilian butt
lifts are a big craze now can you tell
us what procedure what the procedure is
and the precautions that come with it
okay so my resilient butt lifts are a
procedure where you take fat from one
part of the body or several parts like
the abdomen the arms the thighs
and you wash the fat prepare it and you
inject it in the buttock it's the
fastest growing procedure in plastic
surgery it's also the most dangerous and
it's turning out to be the most fatal in
fact it's so fatal it's even more fatal
than like an
and ectomy or alcohol bladder operation
we think that this operation should be
banned is just too dangerous the blood
vessels of the butt are very fragile
very small and there are very short
distance from the blood vessels that
lead to your heart and lungs don't do it
do you ever encounter a botched surgery
so extreme it made you nervous to
perform on that everyone that's very
routine for us the botched surgeries
particularly season 5 are so extreme
because our skill level has gone up so
they really make us nervous because at
the end of the day we're trying to
redefine impossible now the impossible
seems to be more possible don't you
agree boom right there that's pretty
good right that was good for the most
common celebrity patients I use as a
reference for the type of work they want
done so in our office let's say for
years and beyond that was a huge thing
well it was Brad Pitt or Angelina Jolie
but now it's not anymore it's just like
we spoke about it's the selfie
dysmorphia where they have facetune go
in there change their whole complexion
especially and that's what they want a
better-looking version of themself ok
interesting answer but to answer the
actual question you have to who are the
celebrity Bagan Markel yeah Kate
Middleton 8 mil Tate Middleton those
that have about her rhinoplasty or nose
actually she didn't have one but she has
a beautiful nose a little bit more
natural okay so based on this one I'm
gonna ask the next one okay cuz that one
what made you want to take on botched
cases you answer that one yeah so well
I'm sitting with the producers of the
house why of years ago and we just
finished doing the housewives so the two
of us were talking and I said why don't
we think about taking patients that I've
had very bad plastic surgery
and trying to fix them on TV I said well
we need someone else that's gonna help
me my good old buddy Terry Dubrow so I
called him he was sick in bed 103 fever
and he goes that's the stupidest idea
I've ever heard yeah then look we are
now yeah season 5 and never coming
season 6 that crazy
can you describe one of the most bizarre
box surgery you've ever dealt with so
right now there's a huge explosion in
buttock augmentation where people taking
fat from their abdomen and injecting
their buttock the problem is one it's
very dangerous and two
to get enough fat to actually make the
buttock bigger cosmetic surgeons aren't
overdoing it they're taking so much more
than they should and it's causing
scarring and deformities of the areas
they're taking it from so not only are
we having problems with the
liposuctioned areas but once you put in
the butt and it dies and it's a problem
wait till you see the next three or four
or five episodes coming up on botched
because there's a lot of butt problems
so you just follow your sleep was the
how did you see because it was it was
there a moment of this and I hear we
noticed some when I'm watching botched
this season I've looked at myself a few
time you're falling honestly what's the
difference between a cosmetic surgeon
and a plastic surgeon this is critical
one of the main reasons why the jabbar
botched procedures are exploding go you
can actually take a weekend course and
call yourself a cosmetic even if you're
a radiologist a plastic surgeon but we
have residences that trained in these
procedures and in fellowships so we are
specialists in the plastic surgery nough
we here my dentist in my nose job but my
dentist is a cosmetic surgeon I have
news for you if your doctor calls
himself a cosmetic surgeon that may be a
big red bag so you always want to find
that when you're doing an investigation
what type of doctor are you going to and
are they board-certified in that
specialty the final one is what was your
first botched surgery there was a case
where this woman had had like 14 breast
surgeries and her left breast was a
shriveled up scarred down knuckle of a
breast and the right one was like
vertically or you know this one was sort
of this thing and this one was looks
like a crab claw and they said go ahead
fix it go what box has taught us is how
to fix the impossible but I would say
season five is completely different
because we're doing people who have
congenital deformities traumatic
deformities and bad plastic surgery it's
even harder and this season is weirdly
funnier
and he's got a new girlfriend and she's
28 so she free the first time he took
his teeth out put it on the bedside
glass you know and she went one he said
my dentures that one is yeah she's
awesome and she's mad about the edge
very tolerant you don't know very
desperate because she tolerated
wonderful the dentures in the glass by
the bed this has been great yeah a lot
of fun they have so much BuzzFeed we
really enjoyed it make sure you watch
season 5 a botched it 9:00 p.m. Eastern
8:00 p.m. Central on Wednesdays only on
it yeah bye-bye
[Music]